One attack on confidentiality is called eavesdropping,
where an attacker, Eve, might gain unauthorized
access to information being sent between Alice
and Bob. So for example, if Alice and
Bob were chatting on instant message, or if Alice sends an email to Bob, the
potential exists In other words, there's a threat that Eve might be able to hear
that communication. There are various packet sniffing
tools, such as wireshark and tcpdump, that
set a machine's networking interface card into
what's called promiscuous mode. If Alice, Bob,
and Eve are on the same local area network Where packets are being flooded.
For example, if they where being connected
by a hub that flooded all packets everywhere,
or if the learning switch did not have an entry for Alice or Bob then Eve might
be able to hear some of those packets.
If the network interface card is in promiscuous mode.
Than Eve's machine will be able to capture
some of the packets that are being exchanged between
Alice and Bob. Its worth thinking about how different
types of traffic might reveal important information about communication.
For example, the ability to see DNS
look-ups would provide the attacker information about, say,
what websites you're visiting. The ability to capture
packet headers might give the attacker information, not
only about where you're exchanging traffic, but what
types of applications you're using. And the ability
to see a full packet payload would allow
an attacker to effectively see every single thing
that you are sending on the network. Including
content you're exchanging with other people. Such as private
message, email communication, and so forth. Given the
ability to see a packet, Eve might not only
listen to that packet, but might also modify
it and re-inject it into the network, potentially after
altering the state of the packet. If additionally Eve
could suppress the original message Let's consider an attack
on authenticity. If, in addition to being able to observe packets that traverse
the network, Eve could re-inject packets after
having modified them, and suppress Alice's original
message, then Eve could effectively impersonate Alice.
This is sometimes called a 'Man in
the Middle' attack. Alice could also make it appear as though this message came
from Alice. In which case, the attack would be an attack on message integrity.